We first went to our design team to get
a design that not only better reflects
material, but provides substantial
improvements in utility.
We’ve looked at the material
design specification.
Specifically, how colors, elevation, and
animation can be used to create
delightful user experiences.
We covered tools and technique to
help create both material design and
responsive designs, including Toolbar,
CardView, Recycler view,
and GridLayout.
We've looked at using dimensions,
graphs, and
included layouts to simplify our
responsive designs for tablet's.
Finally, we've covered some simple
techniques to create L specifics and
L style animations in your applications.
With all of this, we've implemented
a new, completely refreshed design for
Sunshine that brings us much closer
to a production application.